the Russian defense Ministries released
video that it says shows forces
repelling Ukrainian troops in the
southeastern zapuricia region earlier
defense minister Sakai shago said krieve
suffered heavy losses in a failed
assault Russia controls 80 percent of
the zabaricia region keeps not commented
and its downplaying reports that its
expected counter-offensive is underway
Ukraine's president of Vladimir
zielinski has been praising his troops
for a week what he called results
further east in the Donetsk region
we are in constant communication with
our military the commanders of the
horiza and tavria group are forces with
all those involved in the most heated
combat areas Donetsk region faces very
tough battles but there is a result and
I am grateful to everyone who ensures
this result
Jonah Hall's joining us now live from
Kiev so what more do we know about
what's been going on Jonah
well that statement from Vladimir
zielinski on Thursday night one of his
Nike statements of course tells us quite
a lot and it tells us very little at the
same time he's talking about uh renewed
hostilities in the East around the town
of bakmud that City in the East that
remember Russia claimed control of just
last month scene of some of the
longest-running battles of the war a
place of almost no strategic value
whatsoever but huge symbolic value to
both sides he said there are results I
am grateful to those who achieve them
well done in backwood step by step and
he also talks about in very very brief
terms military activity elsewhere but
specifically says I will give no further
details well that is very much in
keeping with the official line around
questions to do with Ukraine's summer
counter-offensive is it happening is it
still in its Preparatory phases Ukraine
says it simply will not give a running
commentary we did get a little more
detail a few days ago from the deputy
defense minister in her brief thing
about that Motu which she described as
quote the epicenter of hostilities she
talked about incremental advances being
made on four villages in the nearby
vicinity of bakmut suggesting to
analysts the possibility that Ukraine
was trying to mount an encirclement of
back mode to track the Russian forces
who have occupied the city inside it and
remember backwood is not the only focus
of renewed military activity along a
very long front line in the East and the
South uh word on Thursday largely from
the Russian side you mentioned it there
about four advances in the zaporizia
region in the South that Russia said it
had repelled Russian bloggers suggest
those advances were ongoing even
overnight and again leading analysts to
suggest the possibility that this was
Ukraine trying to punch through and cut
off Russian supply lines in the South
part of the counter-offensive part of
Preparatory operations ahead of it we
simply don't know Ukraine is not saying
Jonah thank you very much indeed Jonah
Hall talking to us from Keith we're
going to go to journalist Julio who's in
Moscow so as Jonah was telling us there
are a lot of reports talking about
activity in the front lines particularly
around the zaparisha region what's the
news from the Russian side
yeah exactly so we hear that military
actions have intensified in many
directions and France now there is a lot
of activity in the zaparosia and bahmoud
directions Russian military bloggers
call the Ukrainian attacks a failure
according to them uh Ukrainian forces
and successfully tried to attack the
Russian military forces in the zaparosa
direction according to them
since midnight the Armed Forces of
Ukraine have tried several times to
attack the positions of Russian Fighters
with artillery and Russian aircraft were
also used there but according to the
bloggers the ukrainians failed to break
through the Russian defenses and uh the
front and the front hasn't changed we
were also hearing from from bahmoud the
ukrainians are trying to advance on the
northern and southern flanks of bahmoud
the Russian military managed to knock
out several Army Vehicles as they say
including inventory fighting Vehicles
armored personnel carriers and tanks and
speaking about the Russian border region
of belga road so basically it's not
quite there either and we see reports
that Russian Artillery men dealt a
powerful blur to the positions of the
Armed Forces of Ukraine on the border of
Ukraine and the Belgard region
destroying a Ukrainian strongholder but
if we want to have a clearer picture we
just have to wait for official
information and results from from from
from from
Russian officials and analysts that's
Julio sharp of Oliver talking to us from
Moscow shilia thank you very much indeed